[Aplausos]
[Música]
fundamentalismo narcotráfico terrorismo
lucha de guerrillas no importa el nombre
que utilicemos porque creo que hay un
amplio consenso en que todos estos
grupos son los malos
[Música]
e
la gran pregunta es cómo combatirlos
como vencerles o en términos de starwars
como impedir que darth sidious el
emperador se haga para siempre con el
control de toda la galaxia su arrogancia
de piel de maestro joe pues bien en los
últimos tiempos parece que la respuesta
más normal y desde luego la que piden
muchas personas es la estrategia de
utilizar toda la fuerza disponible
ejércitos bombardeos boicots comerciales
diplomáticos vamos lo que viene a ser un
escenario de guerra total
el problema amigos es que aunque estas
acciones muchas veces pueden ser
necesarias casi siempre nos olvidamos de
una parte esencial de la estrategia una
parte menos llamativa pero que es
imprescindible para derrotar a los malos
[Música]
de hecho en muchas ocasiones si solo
utilizamos la fuerza el resultado si es
que lo hay puede incluso ser
contraproducente en este vídeo sin ir
más lejos vamos a ver algunos casos de
grandes victorias contra los malos en
las que si se utilizó la fuerza pero
ésta no fue ni con mucho la verdadera
protagonista del éxito
[Música]
y aquí tenemos la primera pregunta clave
a que parte de la estrategia nos estamos
refiriendo pues amigos precisamente a la
que impide que los malos puedan hacerse
con el apoyo popular que al fin y al
cabo es lo que necesitan para reclutar a
los milicianos o terroristas y hacerse
también con recursos para llevar a cabo
sus siniestros planes hablamos de la
parte de la estrategia que pasa por
buscar lo que podemos llamar el
empoderamiento económico puede
parecernos ojo que este tipo de cosas no
son importantes para vencer a estos
grupos pero en este vídeo vamos a
demostrar que sí lo son cualquier
intento o anuncio de destruir al
terrorismo está condenado desde el
comienzo porque es un fenómeno impulsado
por dinámicas sociales después de al
qaeda vino el isis se podría destruir
racc a la capital del califato en síria
y descabezar al estado islámico pero
otra organización puede tomar su lugar y
volverse global por cierto hemos
preparado este vídeo a partir de una
sugerencia muy interesante y muy bien
documentada de nuestro suscriptor juan
lópez así que desde aquí todo nuestro
reconocimiento juana
esto volvamos a la faena en este caso
para desplazarnos hasta nuestro querido
perú
[Música]
el perú y la amenaza de sendero luminoso
vamos a suponer amigos de visual polític
que nos hemos montado en el delorean de
doc y hemos viajado atrás en el tiempo
de acuerdo con él hoy yo creo que si vas
a construir una máquina del tiempo en un
coche por qué no hacerlo con clase pues
bien estamos en 1990 en este momento
sendero luminoso un grupo terrorista de
corte marxista leninista controla la
mayor parte del perú su poder es tan
grande atentos que la run corporation un
potente zintan de washington orientado
al análisis militar y de seguridad le ha
dicho al mismísimo departamento de
defensa de los eeuu que sendero luminoso
es una organización prácticamente
inexpugnable los andes y que en dos años
como mucho este grupo se hará con el
control de todo el país miembros de la
comisión de derechos humanos de la trama
de diputados hemos registrado en
diversas oportunidades denuncias de
asesinatos masivos en algunos casos han
involucrado hasta cien personas muertas
pero que 'sendero luminoso' y sobre todo
de donde surge para responder a estas
preguntas tenemos que mirar un poco más
atrás en el tiempo vayamos hasta finales
de la década de los 70
[Música]
en ese momento el perú tenía un problema
el ascensor social no funcionaba es
decir me explico si nacía es pobre
vivías pobre y tus hijas y tus hijos
serían pobres pero por qué ocurría esto
pues en buena medida porque la
burocracia impuesta por las élites para
proteger claro está su estatus y sus
intereses ahogaba cualquier oportunidad
de prosperar
[Música]
y en aquel momento en el perú todo era
muy complicado montar un negocio
legalizar unas tierras heredadas
contratar a alguien el resultado es que
los pobres estaban condenados a vivir en
la informalidad y esto entraña
muchísimos problemas con la informalidad
la seguridad jurídica desaparece no
puedes pedir préstamos por ejemplo para
invertir en tu propio negocio tampoco
puedes acceder a contratos públicos y
así un largo etcétera etcétera etcétera
de cosas fijaros según las
investigaciones del prestigioso
economista peruano hernando de soto
abrir un taller de confección demoraba
289 días y costaba ojo 31 veces el
salario mínimo mensual de la época
vamos que o era rico o no tenías nada
que hacer la gente ya también son
peruanos y todos debemos apoyarnos pero
simplemente la gente como tiene un poco
más de dinero ha hecho un cruce para que
la gente de acá la gente más humilde no
invada para ella y había cosas aún
peores
por ejemplo legalizar un pedazo de
tierra podía llevar hasta 15 años
queréis saber cuál fue el resultado de
todo ello pues la exclusión económica de
muchísimas
y la imposibilidad fáctica de competir
con lo que las élites conservaban sus
privilegios y este tipo de políticas
siempre generan muchísima desigualdad y
sobre todo muchísima frustración en ese
momento surge sendero luminoso es cierto
este grupo maoísta no nace para luchar
contra esta burocracia pero sí es verdad
que consigue crecer y ganar apoyos
gracias en buena medida a toda esa
frustración a la pobreza y a la
desigualdad
[Música]
claro que la alternativa de sendero
luminoso era aún peor y de eso se dieron
cuenta muy pronto muchos campesinos y
trabajadores de las áreas rurales que se
negaban por ejemplo a colectivizar la
tierra que era algo que defendía sendero
luminoso para defenderse
muchos de estos campesinos crearon
comités de autodefensa las llamadas de
casas rurales pero a pesar de algunos
avances
apenas se consiguió nada entre otras
cosas porque no tenían el apoyo del
gobierno no había colaboración
probablemente porque muchos de los
campesinos eran cocaleros llegó el
momento en que venía en sendero nos
mataban venía alguien de la huerta
hermana también de mataban porque nos
confundía y esto en sí mismo era un
problema grandísimo por un lado los
militares combatían ciegos no sabían
distinguir por ejemplo a un campesino de
un miembro de sendero luminoso lo que
provocó muchísimas víctimas inocentes y
esto a su vez se traducía claro está en
más apoyos para sendero luminoso los
dirigentes de las becas me contaron que
los militares en combate no sólo eran
ciegos de vista sino también del
pues la mayoría de ellos no hablaban
quechua el desastre era total y como
hemos visto todo apuntaba a que el perú
caería pronto en manos de este grupo
terrorista pero espera su momento porque
en la década de los 90 se probó una
nueva estrategia
la increíble victoria del perú sobre el
sendero luminoso por un lado y gracias a
un convenio firmado con eeuu en el 91 el
gobierno de perú reconoció que los
cocaleros no eran por definición
narcotraficantes sino simplemente
campesinos esto permitió que el ejército
no solo les dejara en paz sino que
incluso comenzara a cooperar con las
becas por otro lado se inició un
ambicioso plan de reformas para
favorecer la integración económica de
los excluidos por ejemplo se redujeron
un 75% los trámites burocráticos que
bloqueaban el acceso a la actividad
económica se reconocieron y se
formalizaron ojos cientos de miles de
propiedades y también se legalizaron más
de medio millón de empleos la situación
la verdad cambió muy rápido
sendero luminoso perdió prácticamente
cualquier apoyo y se enfrentó a una
poderosa fuerza de choque compuesta por
más de 120 mil campesinos y 30.000
soldados ahora tenían motivación y
medios suficientes para luchar entre
otras cosas porque los pobres ahora
tenían la oportunidad de prosperar
pues bien en el 92 sender luminoso era
ya historia y su líder abimael guzmán
estaba entre rejas eso sí por desgracia
amigos este grupo criminal dejó a sus
espaldas casi 70 mil vidas perdidas
[Música]
y del perú de los años 90 nos vamos
hasta principios del siglo 21
no no no
la estrategia del general p 3
del petróleo ha sido uno de los
generales más importantes de eeuu en los
últimos tiempos e incluso se habló de su
posible carrera a la casa blanca aunque
amigos esta posibilidad quedó truncada
en 2012 por un escándalo que le obligó a
dimitir había compartido información
clasificada con su biógrafa y amante
pero no no es esta parte de su vida la
que nos interesa la enorme popularidad
que alcanzó este general tuvo mucho que
ver con sus éxitos desde que en 2007 el
presidente george bush le nombrará
comandante jefe de las tropas
norteamericanas en irak y ojo porque el
destino no era precisamente fácil irak
era en esa época un completo desastre
aún más que hoy en día y las tropas
estadounidenses se enfrentaban a
muchísimos problemas
[Música]
pues bien el general sabía que las cosas
no podían continuar así así que cambió
por completo el enfoque de la lucha y
dejó a un lado la estrategia inicial que
consistía simplemente en apostar por la
abrumadora superioridad militar y no
sólo dejó a un lado defendió
abiertamente que limitar la estrategia
al campo militar era del todo
contraproducente
[Música]
el general p 3 cambió el sistema de
juego y puso sobre la mesa la necesidad
de que el ejército estadounidense se
implicara con la sociedad y cobrarse una
comprensión social cultural y religiosa
de los acontecimientos bajo sus órdenes
el ejército estadounidense comenzó a
cooperar con las fuerzas locales con los
líderes tribales empezó a prestar
atención a los problemas sociales y
económicos de la población también a la
reconstrucción etcétera
nuestras fuerzas tienen que esforzarse
para proteger y servir a la población
incluso aunque parezca mentira el
ejército norteamericano comenzó a
diferenciar entre grupos terroristas y
organizaciones políticas religiosas o
civiles hasta la llegada del general p 3
para los estadounidenses todos eran lo
mismo enemigos el éxito de la nueva
estrategia fue total
el general dio la vuelta por completo a
la campaña en poco tiempo 100.000
voluntarios iraquíes de tribus que antes
eran consideradas como enemigas pasaron
de enfrentarse a los soldados
estadounidenses a luchar codo con codo
con ellos y la situación en irak claro
para el ejército yanqui cambió por
completo
creo que él jugó un papel histórico el
general p 3 es sin duda el héroe del
momento bien hace algo más de 15 años el
presidente de eeuu george bush declaró
la guerra global contra el terrorismo
desde entonces la gran potencia
norteamericana ha gastado cientos de
miles de millones de dólares en esta
cruzada y es verdad se han conseguido
muchos éxitos entre ellos acabar con más
de 100 líderes terroristas sin embargo a
pesar de ello hoy occidente sigue siendo
tanto más vulnerable ante los
extremistas así que amigos tal vez ha
llegado la hora de impulsar la parte de
la estrategia que no está relacionada
con la fuerza por cierto si quieres
conocer cuál es la peor pesadilla de
donald trump no te pierdas este vídeo
que hicimos sobre la incipiente alianza
entre china y rúsia pero bueno respecto
a este vídeo respecto a cómo vencer a
los malos tú qué crees solo útiles las
estrategias que hemos visto para
derrotarle crees que la parte económica
el trato con la población debería tener
más protagonismo en las políticas de
seguridad y antiterrorismo como siempre
puedes dejarnos tu opinión y tus
impresiones en los comentarios además si
este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
no dudes en darle a like y por supuesto
si aún no te has suscrito no
desaproveches esta ocasión hoy tenemos
una promoción fantástica un dos por uno
y encima gratis hoy te puedes suscribir
a visual político y también a visual
política en inglés completamente gratis
así que ya sabes no pierdas la ocasión
un saludo y hasta pronto